-Hey, everyone.
This past weekend,
we lost an absolute legend.
TV host and
our good friend Regis Philbin
passed away at 88 years old.
Regis got his start
as an NBC page
at "The Tonight Show,"
right here,
when Steve Allen was the host.
But the big break for him
was in 1967,
when he became famous
as the sidekick
on "The Joey Bishop Show."
He could do everything.
He could sing.
He was funny.
He was really funny.
He was an entertainer.
He always was game
to do a bit or dress up.
He would do anything
for a laugh.
I loved him.
My grandparents loved him.
They introduced me.
My mom and dad loved him.
Between his early career
and his time on
"Regis and Kathie Lee"
and "Regis and Kelly,"
he was part of all of our lives.
He would tell funny stories
about his night out
in Manhattan the night before
and tell them with such
humor and class and grace.
And, personally, I loved that he
never forgot his Irish roots,
and as someone who grew up
in an Irish family,
I could relate to
all of those stories.
When I started to become famous
on "Saturday Night Live"
and people would ask,
"What's it like when people
recognize you on the street?",
I would be like,
"I feel like Regis."
And everyone understood that.
There was no need
for explanation,
'cause he was
the king of New York.
I was lucky enough to be on
his show as a guest,
and he was also on my show
numerous times.
We got to know each other
pretty well.
He'll be remembered as
a genuinely nice person,
a funny human, a good husband,
father, and grandfather.
And he always had that smile,
and when Irish eyes are smiling,
well, they'll steal
your heart away.
Regis, we'll miss you.